i love
a great party but i hate bad food and
often the two things go together
i think one of the reasons is that home
cooks get intimidated by the thought of
cooking
for large crowds so they give up and
serve shop bought food instead
but trust me with a bit of planning and
great recipes
it's easy this is my ultimate party food
first up a great brunch for a crowd
spicy mexican eggs
for a sophisticated party lunch you can
pre-prepare
beetroot cured salmon and a chocolate
mint cake
little sheets of glass beautiful my
eldest daughter megan will be helping me
rustle up some amazing dishes for a
relaxed
ramsay get-together but with
irresistible
smoky pulled pork don't tell mom thank
you
and simple but delicious sides of
broccoli slaw and crushed potatoes with
spring onions and grilled cheese
i've never had this so good these are my
ultimate party recipes
that will entertain and sustain a house
full of guests for breakfast
lunch and dinner starting with a
breakfast that can't fail
to get your guests fired up and ready to
party spicy mexican eggs
this is a very classic mexican style
brunch dish
bold kick-ass flavors slice the chili
seeds in garlic sliced
nice and thinly tablespoon of olive oil
i'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch can see you
right through to dinner
now to start the sort of spicy fragrant
tomato sauce
get your cumin in there garlic chili
roasted cumin red onions already sounds
mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in
with your tomatoes never embarrassed
using
good canned tomatoes i do all the time
cooking at home
now by reducing that you sort of come
down to a delicious paste
leave that to simmer next canned beans
called black beans
these are authentically mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas
will work just fine just rinse them a
little bit of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb
leaving the dense beans to luxuriate in
the spicy tomato sauce will allow them
to soften
and soak up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven-proof dish
from my spicy egg brunch to baking
now just get some of that oil around the
outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half
and then just stick them to the side
bees are a staple in mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little
flaps i want that crisp shell on the
outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg
and just make a little hole in there and
then crack
the egg into the again use a little
point
put your egg in there one two
three four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside
almost like it's a little dug out and
then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
montgomery cheddar
i want to grate the tortilla shell as
well so get generous with it on the top
and we'll season that with these little
babies little chili flakes
they're my little secret weapon and
they're going to spice up that egg
just salt a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible it's a little bit
of coriander to finish it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started
spicy mexican eggs and a crispy tortilla
[Music]
shell
coming up my ultimate food for a lunch
or evening party
but first here's a closer look at the
key ingredients you'll need and a few
pointers
on what to look for when you're buying
them
[Music]
chocolate the ultimate comfort food
addictive
and indulgent the chocolate making
process begins by grinding roasted cocoa
beans
quality chocolate should contain at
least 70 cocoa solids
it should give a distinctive crisp snap
when broken
and start melting in your hand after
just a few seconds
and there'll be no skimping on the
quality for my party lunch
chocolate mint cake
[Music]
pork shoulder is an easy to cook
flavoursome joint and can be bought on
the bone or rolled
its relatively cheap price makes it a
great choice when you're feeding a crowd
marbled with fat to keep it moist during
cooking it's also the cut of choice for
barbecue pulled pork
known affectionately in the u.s as
boston butts
i'll be cooking my delicious version of
this meltingly good export
as the star guest of my dinner party
sodium chloride or salt as a mineral
essential to human life
is also one of the most widely used
seasonings in the world
its lack of aroma belies its strong
taste which both enhances the natural
flavor of food
and stimulates our taste buds this
seasoning of all seasonings is processed
in various ways and comes in all
different colors and forms
but for me the finest in flavor is
crystallized sea salt
the product of evaporated sea water and
it's what i'll be using to cure my
salmon
the main course for my super simple but
spectacular party lunch
[Applause]
i think the best dishes for lunch
parties are the things that everyone can
help themselves too
i also prefer dishes that pack a really
big flavor punch and look impressive
party food shouldn't be subtle here are
a couple of dishes for my ultimate lunch
party
the secret behind curing salmon is in
the flavouring you're curing it with
for a hint of the exotic and aromatic my
favorite starting point
is to grind coriander seeds coriander
seeds are
citrusy it's got that nice orangey
flavour and it goes brilliantly well
with salmon
mix that with your salt and
your sugar they may look like a lot of
salt and sugar but once they've done
their job of cold cooking or curing the
salmon
most of it will be washed away next the
grated zest of two oranges
some fresh pepper
and then mix in one of my favorite
ingredients
grated beetroot beetroot gives
a really nice sort of rooty earthy
flavor great
for curing it stains the salmon as well
and it just
elevates it now you'll see
what's happening now with a beetroot
there's salt and sugar
breaking it down see how wet it's
becoming
now that beetroot is ready for the
salmon
if you've got a big party 10 or 20 get a
whole side of salmon
fillet it and get it pinbone by a
fishmonger if it's six or ten guests
then
this chunk in the middle is like the
sort of middle part of a phillips steak
the best of the best
pour on your beetroot and basically what
we're gonna do now is sort of pack it
with all the beetroot
and look at that i mean it looks
fantastic
next cover your bee rooty salmon with
clim film
take your tray lightly press
and they get something substantial
something heavy a pot
or a pan or some tins the weight on top
just speeds up the process
[Music]
place your salmon in the fridge to cure
for at least eight hours or even better
overnight to follow my deliciously light
and simple salmon
a devilishly indulgent dessert nothing
beats a great cake a sort of a show-off
trophy
for party food so i'm gonna make the
most amazing flowerless chocolate cake
but with a twist first thing first make
the caramel
flatten the sugar never stir a caramel
rule number one
now keep the pan nice and flat i'm gonna
flavor this caramel with a little bit of
mint
give it a little chop sprinkle that
into the caramel don't get the caramel
too dark
just nice and light a little teaspoon of
oil onto the tray
and rub that in and then pour
out your caramel if i was making a
caramel sauce
then i'd put butter and cream into the
caramel but i want this nice
minted brittle running through my cake
whilst the caramel cools down on the
tray i'm going to make my cake
first melt good quality dark chocolate
in a bain-marie
heating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats
always in a bowl over boiling water
in a mixing bowl sugar two whole eggs
and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs and the sugar
the lighter that texture in the center
of the chocolate cake
next melt some butter into your warm
dark chocolate and stir
was that really nice sheen velvety rich
and
tasting amazing add that to your sugar
and your eggs
now give that a really good mix now when
you're making
flourless desserts it really is
important to work harder
incorporating air especially with the
yolks and the sugar
that natural height needs to take place
at the beginning
look at that looks like the perfect
chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two-thirds of
the way there with your whites
and then just sprinkle in the sugar it's
almost like a
meringue and the firmer you make these
now
the more it will elevate your cake in
the oven
that's what you call a stiff peak
in with the whites before i start mixing
that
i'm gonna get my caramel just start
breaking that up it's like glass sheets
of glass
beautiful save some of your minty
caramel shards
for decoration and use a rolling pin to
break up the rest into small pieces
sprinkle that in says we start to slice
that chocolate cake
you'll come across that nice crunch take
your cake tin
make sure it's lined with the
greaseproof paper
on the bottom nicely greased pour this
in
a few sharp taps on a hard surface will
rid your cake mixture of any air pockets
that could create holes in your cake
sit that in the oven 180.
after 35 minutes my chocolate mint cake
is cooked and whilst it cools down
i can whip up a peppermint cream topping
[Music]
add sifted icing sugar and a few drops
of peppermint extract to double cream
and whisk until it's just holding its
shape
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small border free
to make it easier to cut for a cake that
can't fail to attract attention at your
party
scatter over the remaining caramel mint
shards
[Music]
now to unveil my incredible beetroot
cured salmon
off with the weight my tray
and look what's happened to the salmon
absolutely beautiful you can just tell
how delicious that's going to be with
this sort of
sheen give that a little rinse and cold
water
with your kitchen roll pat it nice and
dry beautiful
traditionally cured salmon would be
sliced into large thin pieces like
smoked salmon but
i like to cut mine into thin strips it's
easier and it will show off its beauty
slice down get to the skin and then
flick your knife out
that for me is a much better way of
eating cured salmon
the difference the colors that nice dark
rich ruby red
now when you've got cured salmon this
good
trust me you just need a salad melba
toast
or some stunning bread look how many
slices of salmon
we've got that's the secret for me to
any good party
a couple masterpieces simple
straightforward ingredients
but done properly nice
my sumptuous beetroot cured salmon and
for dessert a divine chocolate mint cake
party food with the wow factor
[Music]
when you're working in restaurants your
job is to make sure people have a great
time
you're there to make sure they're
enjoying themselves
believe me after 20 odd years in the
business i've got experience
in this department and the golden rule
for success is
don't get intimidated get organized here
are three of my ultimate dishes for a
great
evening party if there's one thing all
the ramsay children love
it's a good family party and my eldest
megan is going to help me with the party
piece
mouth-watering smokey pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now
this is incredible there's the shoulder
yeah
and look there's the shoulder blade if
you go through here there's a knuckle
there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called
a butt the slower you cook it the more
juicy it is
and it's great for big parties because
you just come along and get your fork
and shred it a delicious
smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay i'm gonna
leave the roots on
okay because i want this to sit
underneath the port
it gives it a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now
i'll peel the garlic okay i'd like you
to crush the garlic we're gonna make a
really nice little paste okay
go on maggie come on come on come on
nice good girl one more crush
come on maggie i'm coming oh sorry about
that
just give that little cup there now this
is a beauty paprika smoked paprika
i love it so three nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons
of brown sugar salt please
and pepper could go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now olive oil
in
mix that with some thyme in there so we
got a sort of fragrant
rub time stalks underneath
so that's even more flavor going on on
the bottom pour that
all over it now this is where you gotta
be really quick
okay and sort of rub that mashed sausage
in almost
exactly that smells amazing
honestly you just drizzle a little touch
of olive on top of that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinading of the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if i was
doing this for a sunday
and start marinating thursday friday so
it gets even tastier
right quite easy as well to make it's
very easy five and a half to six hours
in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are going to pimp some shot-bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you have to twist
to us
yeah there's so many things something
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness
but there's some heat coming okay and
i've got a little bit
off you love this chipotle smoked
chipotle paste
i love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah you can
use it for any sandwiches really any
sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
i've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's our nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready
just time to knock up a couple of tried
and tested party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water
skins and all meanwhile finely dice
sweet pickled gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty grilled cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush
and add your spring onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling
of grated gria these simple
cheesy crushed potatoes are equally
delicious served hot
or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make a really nice
fresh broccoli salad now these are
called florets
and that's the best part of the broccoli
okay the bit that everybody wants
once they're off i'm gonna slice the
broccoli
mm-hmm never had raw broccoli before
it's always been cooked
really when you dress this with the
dressing it's incredible
now a little season early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in
teaspoon of sugar please daddy little
smell
cider vinegar mmm there you go
finely chopped shallot in with the
broccoli
so delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
currants i love them that gives that
nice sort of chewy texture
all right lift up your bowl please nice
and gently half of that
in the middle please thank you and stop
and then mix that up with me
good girl a little taste
so good and this kind of salad that
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow for
this look at this
megan honestly that is amazing
it's beautiful that is incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that i
thought let's have a tiny bit
just before we go to the table just a
little bit
honestly meg don't tell mom
thank you honestly do i do it i'm gonna
do it
that is incredible so good you promised
me
you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go come on
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cook smokey
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple sides of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw
deliciously yummy dishes that will have
your family friends
and work buddies coming back for more
right how's the ball
this is very good thank you daddy it's
very tasty
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck